je suis ravi vraiment ravi d'accueillir
Monsieur François Baayou au commissaire
au
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Plan bon tout ce que Cyril a dit est
vrai il a pas donné les
détails mais j'ai été quand j'avais 20
ans ou à peine plus de 20
ans candidat sur la liste nationale de
ce qu'on appelait à l'époque le
scanrac c'est-à-dire le syndicat de
l'éducation nationale de la CFTC et des
Affaires Culturelles je crois me
souvenir bon c'était pas un syndicat
majoritaire si je me souviens bien à
l'époque et si je regarde aujourd
aujourd'hui en effet c'est probablement
ceux qui se sentent de cet esprit ne
sont pas majoritaires non plus mais j'ai
toujours
penser que c'était à partir des
minorités qu'on faisait les futures
majorités alors tous ceux parmi vous qui
ne sont pas majoritaires comprendront ce
que je veux dire c'est ça le combat donc
c'est la première raison et pour moi
c'est une raison très très importante en
en amitié en en
fraternité et puis il y a d'autres
raisons pour lesquelles je suis très
heureux d'être là et dont je voudrais
vous dire un mot euh la première de ces
raisons est que dans le monde dans
lequel nous sommes euh dans le monde que
à certains égards nous subissons euh
dans ce monde-là le courant que vous
représentez euh qui est plus
large que votre seule
organisation qui est plus large que les
mouvements dont je suis responsable et
pour lesquels je suis engagé mais c'est
le même courant c'est un courant qui est
qui a deux
caractéristiques la première c'est qu'il
est réformiste et la deuxième qui est
encore plus importante c'est qu'il est
humaniste or le monde dans lequel nous
sommes à mon sens impose
que nous prenions toute la
dimension de cet idéal ou de cette
pratique réformiste et de cet idéal
humaniste parce
que parce que ce que nous vivons et ce
que nous allons
vivre et je crois que ce que nous allons
vivre est encore
plus
exigeant que ce que nous vivons
aujourd'hui je pense que les mouvements
et les dérives du
monde impose que
soit représenté affirmé
promu cette méthode réformiste qui nous
est
cher je ne crois pas que jamais dans le
monde dans le monde tel que nous l'avons
vécu depuis de siècles je ne crois pas
que
jamais les
approches
extrémistes qui se disent
révolutionnaire je ne crois pas que
jamais ces méthodes et ces pratiques est
apportter à une société quelque chose de
bon l'idée selon
laquelle il faut tout mettre par
terre parce que derrière on aura des
idéau de transparence de
de reconnaissance de la place de
chacun je ne vois pas où sous quelle
latitude et en quel temps ça a apporté
quelque chose de bon ceux qui apportent
quelque chose de bon c'est ceux qui
prennent le monde comme il est et décid
de le reconstruire quand il est délabré
de le consolider quand il est
fragiliser et de le transformer quand
c'est
nécessaire alors c'est une méthode moins
flamboyante que bien d'autres mais c'est
la seule qui puisse tenir
compte de la
réalité d'une
société d'une communauté humaine qui
puisse prendre en compte sa
culture c'est
ces habitudes de
vie et qui puissent en chaque fois que
nécessaire
produire du bien du bon et du nécessaire
voilà pourquoi je crois que il faut que
le grand courant réformiste français
s'affirme comme tel je dis ça comme un
citoyen militant de ce courant depuis
mon mon plus jeune âge et mon plus jeune
âge dans vos
rangs
deuxièmement c'est un courant
humaniste permettez-moi de m'arrêter une
seconde à cela il y
a dans l'univers dans lequel nous sommes
plongé une dérive constante vers la
déshumanisation une dérive constante
vers euh la prise de contrôle des
sociétés humaines par des forces qui
nous dépasse qui ne rendent compte à
personne dont nous ne savons pas de qui
elles sont
constituées et qui s'impos à nous par
leur puissance financière ou la
puissance des outils
qu'il dont ils se
servent et nous au contraire nous
pensons que la seule chose qui mérite
d'être vécu c'est le long
chemin si je puis me permettre cette
expression vers l'humanisation des
hommes des hommes au féminin comme des
hommes au
masculin qu'il soit de plus en plus et
de mieux en mieux hommes et
femmes qu'ils acceptent et qu'ils
prennent en compte toutes les dimensions
de leur
responsabilité comme membre de la grande
famille
humaine je viens de prononcer un mot qui
qui nous caractérise et qui vous
caractérise qui
caractérise qui devrait caractériser
tous les citoyens mais dont dans
l'univers syndical vous êtes parmi ceux
qui le défendent le mieux c'est le mot
de responsabilité et moi j'ai envie de
dire de
coresponsabilité je ne crois pas que
c'est une c'est un grand choix politique
que je vais énoncer là je ne crois pas
que la société démocrtique en
particulier soit coupé en deux entre
ceux qui sont à la base et ceux qui sont
au sommet ceux qui décideraient pour les
autres je crois que l'immense
entreprise de la démocratie de l'idée
que le peuple des
citoyens prend sa part des
décisions cette idée là est une idée
fondatrice et qui n'a jamais été au bout
de ses promesses je pense pas que la
démocratie existe
encore pas plus la démocratie politique
que la démocratie sociale je pense
qu'elle doit
exister je pense que nous avons à la
construire et vous savez bien parce que
c'est votre engagement et votre
vocation nous avons à la construire dans
la cité humaine dans
l'entreprise et dans les communautés
humaines qui l'incarne dans lequel elle
se elle se forme et cette ces trois
idées là
réformiste humaniste et partisan de la
responsabilité et quand on peut de la
coresponsabilité pour l'avenir de la
société française et je peux élargir de
la Société européenne de la société
occidentale des sociétés qui ont un idé
de liberté dans le
monde cette idée là dont vous
êtes un des visages et un des visages
depuis le plus
longtemps vous fêtez vous avez 100 ans
et pardonnez-moi de le dire comme
citoyen comme
militant notre notre famille politique
elle a été fondée il y a 100 ans
1924 vous c'est 23 c'est ça hein 19 19
19 alors vous êtes je vous dois le
respect comme aîné mais enfin on est
assez fier de de porter cet idéal là ça
c'est le premier plan comme citoyen
comme personne
comme animé de d'amitié et de gratitude
pour ceux parmi lesquels j'ai milité
quand j'étais très jeune il un deuxème
point c'est que j'ai la responsabilité
du
plan et ça tombe très bien avec les
documents que j'ai lu avec le discours
de
Cyril à l'ouverture du congrès l'idée
que notre devoir est de prendre en
compte
l'horizon du moyen terme et du long
terme euh il se trouve que les sociétés
d'aujourd'hui à cause de la
touteepuissance des réseaux sociaux des
euh des chaîne
d'information 24h sur
24 le le goût du scandale qu' a notre
société le goût de
l'événement dont on
parle toutes les minutes et toutes les
heures pendant 24 heures et dont on
parlera plus après regardez le l'absence
désormais de la guerre d'Ukraine dans
l'actualité avec la tragédie qui qui se
joue mais dont on ne parle plus et tous
les drames que nous vivons au
Moyen-Orient hélas ils sont de plus en
plus rapidement effacés ils sont
pourtant constitutifs de notre avenir
comme comme humanité comme communauté
humaine et comme communauté comme on dit
géopolitique et donc l'idée que nous
devons prendre en compte réfléchir en
emble et construire ensemble des
horizons politiques et économiques et
sociaux à non pas à à 15 jours mais à 10
ans à 15 ans à 20 ans à 30 ans cette idé
là qui est l'idée même de la
constitution du plan après la guerre
cette idé elle est plus d'actualité
aujourd'hui que jamais pourquoi parce
que pendant des
années notre vie de gouvernement
c'est'est laissé aller à croire que le
marché pouvait répondre à
tout que suffisait de laisser
faire les les grands décideurs
économiques et financiers que les choix
qui seraient imposés seraient par nature
les bons choix je vais le dire
autrement cette
vision là on va dire néolibérale pour
simplifier cette vision là elle pensait
que la somme des intérêts particuliers
constituait l'intérêt général et nous
nous savons que c'est pas vrai et je le
dis dans une famille
syndicale dans une famille démocratique
puisque la démocratie c'est démocratie
sociale et démocratie politique en même
temps cette idée
là est une idée qui s'est révélée fausse
c'est que vous avez depuis toujours
senti comme nécessairement à dépasser
c'est vous qui avait parlé du bien
commun et le bien commun c'est
précisément l'idée que on peut ensemble
conscience avec conscience
euh par la confrontation des des idées
des convictions des valeurs comme on dit
euh on peut précisément définir le but
qu'on veut atteindre et non pas laisser
faire les très grands acteurs économies
et financiers qui vont définir ce but à
votre place et que vous constaterez
simplement les évolutions au lieu de les
vouloir et de les produire alors c'est
très très important parce que ça sur
tous les aspects que vous je n'ai vu que
le projet de votre de votre texte
d'orientation bien sûr puisque vous
allez le voter ce soir c'est ça Cyr oui
et donc mais je vois très bien que
l'idée que nous avons à reconstruire
dans l'intérêt de notre peuple et
peut-être dans un intérêt plus large
encore une capacité d'autonomie
économique une capacité
[Musique]
de définir et
fixer
les les critères de la construction de
notre avenir industriel par exemple et
évidemment tous les sujets que vous
abordez
c'est-à-dire la question
de du durable de la durabilité que vous
allez traiter cet après-midi si j'ai
bien vu tout à l'heure le le l'annonce
sur votre
écran ces sujetsl sont directement en
relation avec ça il y a d'autres
sujets que nous abordons ensemble dans
les discussions que nous nous avons je
veux simplement en aborder deux il y a
le sujet du
travail le plan vient
de
éditer une une étude sur le travail qui
va dans le sens des réflexions que vous
conduisez puisque travailler autrement
c'est un des sujets de votre de votre
congrès
confédéral nous avons abordé la question
au plan avec
avec la petite équipe qui nous permet de
livrer ces analyses et de définir ces
objectifs nous avons pris la question du
travail dans un angle différent de ce
qui lui est réservé ou dévolu dans la
plupart des discussions politiques et
aussi dans la plupart des discussions de
la vie de tous les
jours aujourd'hui la question du travail
est abordée très souvent
sur le mode de la
déploration les gens veulent plus
travailler les jeunes veulent plus
travailler et il y a
différentes façons d'aborder ces constat
négatif nous avons essayé de
comprendre quelle était la question
fondamentale derrière ces choix sur sur
le travail et la question fondamentale
comme vous le dites et comme c'est la
vérité profonde c'est la question du
sens du travail la question
de ce que le travail apporte à celui ou
à celle qui en assume la charge j'ai été
pour tout dire et ça n'est dirigé contre
personne il y a une publicité qui est
sur tous les réseaux sociaux aujourd'hui
depuis peut-être 2 semaines c'est une
publicité de Amazon
qui dit on vous donne un mois de plus de
congé
parental
pour que Jean-Paul
Mohamed puisse s'occuper de
l'essentiel cette
affirmation de publicité
elle signifie que pour les
concepteurs le travail n'est pas dans
l'essentiel et moi je crois que cette
vision là est une vision fausse Dieu
sait c'est pas ici qu'on va dire devant
moi qu'on va dire que la famille n'est
pas importante crucial vitale mais il
n'est pas vrai que on puisse découper
ainsi l'activité professionnelle pas
l'essentiel et la vie familiale
l'essentiel moi je crois que tout ça
constitue l'essentiel ensemble parce que
tout ça c'est le métier d'homme le
métier de femme et d'homme le la la
vocation de notre vie et si l'on se
laisse entraîner à considérer le travail
comme superféatoire comme secondaire
comme à ce moment-là on perd l'exigence
qui consiste à dire il faut que nous
trouvions dans le travail autant de
valorisation autant de réalisation
personnelle pour ceux qui l'assument et
donc on perd la nécessité de revaloriser
le
travail comprenez si c'est si le travail
c'est simplement ce qu'on fait en plus
on vient gagner des sous et on s'en va
alors on se trouve précisément devant la
crise de sens que nous découvrions à
l'instant c'est pourquoi je suis très
reconnaissant à une organisation comme
la vôtre de poser cette question du sens
puis il y a une deuxième type de
question et je suis sûr que nous allons
nous retrouver sur ce sujet c'est que
tous ensemble nous
devons ouvrir les yeux sur le les crises
de société que nous traversons je
voudrais en évoquer une qu'on évoque
souvent avec Cyril quand on parle c'est
la démographie la crise de natalité d'un
pays comme le nôtre qui a perdu 100000
enfants alors que nous sommes plus
nombreux qui a perdu 100000 ou 120000
enfants en quelques années par
an c'est une
traduction d'une crise plus profonde qui
est que
les les jeunes femmes et les jeunes
hommes en âge de faire naître des
enfants ne voi plus le
sens de la transmission de génération en
génération il ne voit plus à quel point
il est vital pour une société comme la
nôtre je vais aller plus loin pour une
civilisation comme la nôtre il ne voit
plus le sens de
transmettre de faire naître de
nouveaux citoyens de nouveaux actifs de
nouveaux penseurs de nouveaux
enseignants et ils ont le sentiment que
le monde est fini nous nous sommes ceux
qui croyons que le monde n'est pas fini
et voilà pourquoi votre existence votre
développement ou en tout cas votre
affirmation
elle touche à quelque chose de très
profond et voilà pourquoi nous sommes de
ceux qui voulons
préserver cette idéale démocratique que
nous formons ensemble démocratie sociale
démocratie politique démocratie qui veut
prévoir l'avenir et voilà pourquoi il y
a entre vos mains une responsabilité
éminente que je suis heureux d'avoir pu
rappeler devant vous pour vous en
remercier merci beaucoup